[Music]
Facebook is an idealistic and optimistic
company for most of our existence we
focused on all the good that connecting
people can do mr. Zuckerberg what is
Facebook doing to prevent foreign actors
from interfering in US elections if
you've messaged anybody this week would
you share with us the names of the
people you've messaged a senator no I
would probably not choose to do that
publicly here I think that maybe what
this is all about
do you believe you're more responsible
with millions of Americans personal data
than the federal government would be the
alien time is really interesting and
fascinating to study it was a time where
pretty much everyone who was involved
was really optimistic about what it
could mean the web is going to be the
defining social moment for computing it
would give free access to knowledge to
people whenever they needed it it
suddenly seemed to shrink the world and
suddenly even being a part of vast
distances for people didn't matter as
much move fast and break things kids
coming out of dorm rooms and starting
companies all the walls that used to
separate people from information and
from each other would be broken down and
used to create again a new open
egalitarian world American society
American political culture allowed these
companies to grow and to mediate all
their interactions now that we have
people were thinking like is technology
good for us is the Internet good for us
this will change everything I think it
was clear that the main goal was like to
get it to a stable version and monetize
it business is working well the majority
of our revenues of course are in
advertising no one really knew how fast
things would evolve no one really knew
how quickly basically how willingly
platforms were willing to collect
sellout users
when I first started covering Silicon
Valley I began to try to understand how
Silicon Valley companies like Facebook
and Google made money what was their
business model the earliest moment that
I can remember when privacy became an
issue internet experience was in 2004
when Google launched Gmail and it was
gonna do that it was gonna finance this
byte by essentially reading all your
emails and then serving you targeted
advertising this is a new thing for most
people because people didn't realize how
Google was financing its operations
until then and suddenly people became
what four savvy about what was happening
on the internet a decade ago
like 15 years ago I would not have
thought this was possible not just you
know in terms of ethically but also
technology wise changing your privacy
settings at this point is you know like
rearranging the chairs after Titanic you
know in a way not only because already a
lot of this data has been collected and
curated but also because you have any
change your settings there are ways for
people to scrape information from these
websites the thing that is interesting
to me the most currently is the result
that algorithms play in the formation of
these online communities the way these
algorithms work is they find patterns in
data by looking at what humans have
provided them as kind of examples this
is one area where bias could actually be
introduced into algorithms if you think
of a word like CEO and a word like man
most likely what you'll see if you map
them into these vector spaces that we
have man here most likely CEO it's going
to be very close to man but very far
away for whom looking at this type of
algorithm you could also envision how a
system like Google would start to use
these diapers
people are really pushing forward for
these algorithms to be used in every
facet of human life without actually
understanding fully the consequences
social media has the power to bring
people together formally like without a
voice we've seen like hopeful stories
like the Arab Spring we've seen the me2
we've seen black lives matter the
Internet is a great organizing tool are
we better off now after the Internet has
come into existence than we were 30
years ago well it's changed that it's
made some things much better but again
influence is how it makes money
platforms generally need to acknowledge
that they have responsibility users
should have a reasonable amount of trust
and a platform and a service they're
using that their data is not being sold
sometimes companies have started to
realize the role that they've played and
are moving towards implementing
solutions to that end here's the
question that all of us kind of answer
given what's happened here while we
should let you self-regulate well
senator my position is not that there
should be no regulation I think the
internet is increasing in embrace
regulation we're going to begin program
with one of the forefathers of virtual
reality he was there in the beginning
since the early 1980s believe he helped
craft a vision for the Internet as a way
to bring people together he's a
scientist a musician and an author and
his new book is ten arguments for
deleting your social media accounts
right now
[Applause]
you've said that we don't have to throw
the whole thing away but you also say
that this internet AI has turned us into
Pavlovian dogs carrying around devices
suitable for what you call mass
behaviour modification by that ah well
there was a time when we used the mail
and I should point out when you sent a
letter by mail nobody else read it you
paid for it but it was strictly your
business it was a remarkable thing
almost unimaginable today so in those
days you could find yourself under
observation by somebody who's trying to
be sneaky and manipulate you one way to
do would be to volunteer for a
psychology test in the basement of the
psych building on campus and then some
undergraduates would be behind the the
one-way mirror trying to get you to do
something or you could get into an
abusive relationship or you could join a
cult you could find yourself on the
wrong side of an interrogation desk you
there all kinds of ways that could
happen but they were all very localized
and unusual now it's happening to
everybody everybody is under constant
observation and constant manipulation
albeit look to just to be very clear
it's slight so at this point the degree
of observation is less than in the
scenarios I just described although it's
getting more so every day but the thing
is slight differences slight behavior
modification applied consistently over
time kinship society it's like compound
interest at any particular moment you
might say oh how much difference could
it make so I saw an ad from the Russian
intelligence warfare people so it got me
a little cranky over something or there
who cares but cumulatively it does have
a statistical effect on the whole
society and then as far as why I'm
asking people to quit I'll tell you why
it's because I love Silicon Valley
I love making digital products I've sold
a company to Google I'm we're
Microsoft I adore my community it's my
home and I don't like you to be passive
sheep customers I want you to be
demanding tough customers and I want you
to make us work to make you happy and
right now you're all turning into
passive sheep and it bugs me because so
if you quit your at least prodding us
you're at least not just sitting there
passively accepting accepting whatever
we feed you so I think would be better
for us I want I want you to challenge us
because that that way we're not
disconnected from the world anymore can
you see that like when you engage with
Silicon Valley when you're tough you're
actually saving us from being like a
band and on some desolate island of the
super empowered you know like you
actually help us he actually you
actually reconnect the world to get
precise about you're saying the trend
lines are being watched in how we do
respond in tiny bits are being lost by
algorithms that can see what the trend
is pointing to and so it subtly changes
our behavior yeah yeah the way it works
is there are very few sort of sneaky
people and cubicles trying to figure out
how to manipulate you directly I mean
there are the Russians have some in
their employé but the much more common
thing that makes the whole system work
is algorithms so the algorithm will do a
little bit of random stuff it'll say
well during what time of the month is
this person more susceptible to this
kind of pitch what about other people
who correlate with this person in some
ways all of these correlations turn into
this statistical I wouldn't call it a
model of you because it wouldn't pass
muster as a scientific model but it's
kind of a predictive portrait of you
that can be used slightly reliably I
mean this stuff is only barely better
than random but but it is a little
better than random and so it gradually
finds a way to engage with you we use
the word engage instead of a dict what I
mean is a dict we gradually addicted to
you through algorithmic exploration
until we find whatever it is that'll
that'll get you what's the business
model behind all of that
well the business model is it's really
kind of interesting I've had occasion to
be at the these events where all the
Silicon Valley companies sell their
biggest advertisers big package deals
for the next year and it's an amazing
spectacle to behold because each of the
companies in turn Facebook and Google
and so on we'll grab a stage and then
present to the biggest advertising
buyers often I kid you not with dancers
and special effects it's like this big
production and if you listen to the way
the companies talk about what they can
do to their own customers the
advertisers you hear this extraordinary
bragging like we can really nail in on a
person we can get them to do something
we can you know and it's actually a
little exaggerated and then the public
faces oh no no we only do things in your
interest but but it really is kind of
two-faced there's this there's this very
aggressive way that the companies sell
themselves and I think what happens to
the advertisers to the people who are
putting all this these many billions of
dollars into the system is they get
scared because they're thinking oh my
god if we don't pay into these companies
it's like we won't exist it's kind of
like an existential version of a mafia
sort of protection racket you know it's
like you're saying like you pay us or
nobody will know about you and so I
think while the official version is that
we're giving you the answer but they're
more useful and then the sales version
is we're able to mind-control people for
your benefit the actual truth is we're
gonna scare you into thinking if you
don't give us money you'll cease to
exist
so I think those are the three different
versions of the same business plan and
if I'm not mistaken you've actually
written somewhere that all of this is
turning us into these are your words
quote you said into [ __ ]
unquote right well I I wanted to sound
presidential
[Laughter]
what happens is when you get somebody
addicted to something whether it's an
opioid or social media their personality
changes they get kind of cranky and
selfish there's this thing anybody who's
known an addict for is will recognize
this and social media addicts do tend to
get this quality which is some call
sometimes called the snowflake
personality where it's almost like
you're asking for a fight they want
attention so badly and so it does kind
of make you into that thing that was
mentioned and I've heard you've pointed
out that some of the tech titans of
which they're not that many don't let
their kids go anywhere near technology
some of my friends in the industry are
shocked i I kind of let my daughter do
whatever she wants I figure she has to
learn her own lessons and they're
shocked like you let her have a phone
like you know she's gonna have to figure
it out but a lot of people are like
incredibly anti tech within the tech
community it's it's it's rather
remarkable and you've also said that
this is approaching something like the
divine right of kings turning us into
people who are following without
realizing that we're following but we're
just giving over to it anyway it is the
strangest thing like I don't have
anything against the individuals I
mentioned because a lot of them are
people I know and I but it's it's really
weird like one of the tech companies is
the first large public company
controlled by a single person and has
all of this power and like why should
that be so it's a very peculiar thing
but we had such a fervent belief in the
myth of the hacker cowboy who would dent
reality in the words of Steve Jobs that
somehow we're we're enacting it one of
the things I'm a little concerned of
actually is that them sometimes when
people in a society chooses like figures
to be godlike figures then they'll tear
them down so they'll elect a Mussolini
and then hang the Mussolini or they'll
elect the Aztec Prince for a year and
then and then sacrifice that person and
I I'm a little concerned about some kind
of
some kind of wave of hatred against tech
which would be totally inappropriate
because we actually are doing something
important what I what I what I ask is
not to hate us but to engage us and
force us to be better you know that's a
much better scenario I can understand
that yet we've seen examples lately
where it's being pointed out to us that
the smartphone's conveying what they're
able to convey are turning P in they're
turning the propagators of maniacal
social violence weaponized in Myanmar
the Rohingya problem and in South Sudan
social media is literally a deadly
weapon in South Sudan explain that yeah
so this has been one of the awful things
that's happened early on there so
Silicon Valley is part of the Bay Area
in California and tends to swing left
right and very early on there was this I
would say a certainty that if you just
let people talk to each other it'll
create positive leftist changes in the
world and one of the first great
triumphs so that was the Arab Spring
like oh we'll just give power to the
people they'll overthrow dictators
they'll create this beautiful democracy
now the thing is the algorithms that are
watching participants in something like
the Arab Spring aren't left or right
they're not humanistic they have no
feelings at all they're just trying to
find any path to maximize addiction and
maximize influence algorithmically just
through searching and eventually they
discover the algorithms discover in a
blind algorithmic way that the negative
emotions the negative people are easier
to engage and so everything starts
tilting towards amplifying those people
so you'll have an Isis that gets even
more mileage from the same tools that
propelled an Arab Spring or you'll get a
research and KKK a neo-nazi movie that
gets even more mileage from the same
nexus of communications that propel the
black lives matter right is an example
that's that happened here and we see
this again and again can I get two
slightly geeky for second please please
okay so
uniques have given this to us so yeah
yeah okay so well I then thank you for
giving us another chance to screw you up
here so in classical behaviorism the
earliest experiments used things like
candy and electric shocks to give people
stimulus response to what they did to
change their behavior right that's the
Skinner box now we we don't yet have
drones hovering over people dropping
candy or electric shocks on them right
that's coming but it's not here yet
so we use symbols like analogous to
Pavlov's Bell but we use social
experience to give people a little
dopamine hits as we call them in the
trade the little positive feeling when
you get retweeted or something and then
the negative ones when you get treated
badly when you get when you get harassed
online insulted and so the thing is that
in in a broad sense positive and
negative stimuli are both powerful and
people but they have different time
profiles so what happens is the positive
ones can take longer to build and can be
broken more quickly and the negative
ones can come up faster so it's it's
faster to get startled or scared than it
is to relax but it takes longer to build
trust than it takes to lose trust so you
can see there there reverses and so
since the algorithms are responding on a
rapid feedback loop they select out and
amplify the negative stuff and that's
why Isis gets more mileage than the Arab
Spring and that's why the Klan gets more
mileage than black lives matter do we
you have to step away and abandon the
free model I I think there's a variety
of possible solutions the one that I'm
really interested in is changing the
underlying business model so if you have
an underlying business model where the
only way you can make a penny is I mean
what we're doing that is so insane can
you imagine if in the old days if you
mailed somebody a letter instead of
buying postage the letter would be free
but some customer would only pay money
if they were confident they could change
the letter in a way that they would
influence events that would be
extraordinary right but that's exactly
what we've done right now if you and I
are to have contact over the Internet
this thing that's supposed to be open
and free the
only way that can be financed is by a
third party who we don't know about who
was just influenced us both and so once
you have that business model it's like
this red carpet invitation to the
Russians and other bad actors and the
Klan and whoever to use it because they
can get incredible mileage out of it of
a disruptive and negative sort so bring
back postage make it paid let pace so in
the old day in the in the days when
Facebook was being founded everybody
thought that the way movies and TV would
be created would be like the Wikipedia
would be this massive volunteer free
thing everybody in Silicon Valley not in
Hollywood we had an honest test that was
tried a lot of people tried to do that
but then we had Netflix HBO Hulu etc and
it turns out that when people pay for TV
we got this thing called peak TV we did
an honest test we got an honest result
so what I want face Facebook to turn
into I don't want the good stuff and
Facebook to disappear I think there's a
lot of extremely positive stuff that
happens on social media I wanted to turn
into a cross between Netflix and Etsy I
want you to pay for it like you pay for
a Netflix so you can get peak social
media but if you do something special
that means a lot I want you to be able
to get money for your craft like you
would on Etsy so I want it I want that
to be the future face it sounds good but
to get a little bit realistic did you
take any technology company would
actually go for this they'll do better I
mean this is just normal capitalism like
it's like this idea of people coming in
from the side and getting in the middle
of everybody in manipulating society and
it's the only business model is not
capitalism it's some bizarre dystopic
thing I mean it's this is just I'm
suggesting just normal capitalism like
people pay for stuff they like and they
have a choice about it it's just normal
and I think would be better for Facebook
it'd be better for Google I think it'd
be better for everybody I think their
shareholders would be happy I think it's
just a better solution if we could
figure out how to have that happen all
at once but let me ask you what was it
you said that this was all making
politics impossible as we understand it
and I must say because but the way the
the rights of individuals for voting at
all was conceived in an age where we
didn't have any
this magical stuff it's changed the
definition of politics almost yeah I
mean we live in a bizarre world out that
just happened recently I feel sorry for
young people who couldn't experience the
contrast with what came earlier where
nothing seems real everything everything
seems like it's manipulated by unseen
forces everybody is on edge all the time
no not not that we had utopia before but
we had a little bit more reality and I
we must get back there to survive I I
don't see how we can survive if we're
insane but one big question is whether
anyone's criticism will matter so
there's a bit of a confusion on this
matter sometime in the Silicon Valley
atmosphere there's this thing like well
if you're optimistic it means you're
complacent because you're sure things
will work out automatically
it'll just naturally get better I don't
think that's ever been true I think we
have progressed and things have gotten
better and the various trend lines of
betterment are very real but every
single increment of that betterment was
due to somebody putting their foot down
and saying things can be better
Jeron linear thank you very much for
joining us and on the positive note
thank you for thank you so much what is
the science behind these AI systems that
are impacting everything from the news
you read healthcare who gets hired
promoted deported what does living in a
world run by algorithms means joining us
now to dig deeper into all of this
director of the Harvard MIT ethics and
governance AI initiative and the Google
former the former Google global public
policy lead for artificial intelligence
and machine learning please welcome Tim
Wang
[Music]
co-founder of the AI now Institute
that's based at NYU she is a research
scientist and founder of the Google open
research Club
please welcome Meredith Whittaker Aviv
Aveda is chief technologist at the
Center for social media responsibility
at the University of Michigan School of
Information he is worth improve provided
research from Amazon for Amazon the MIT
Media Lab for Morgan Stanley Cora Yertle
the toe center for digital journalism
and Google please welcome Aviva Vega and
last but not least a professor of law
Business and Economics at Villanova
University
he's also an affiliated scholar of the
Center for Internet Society at Stanford
Law School please welcome breakfast
and let's start with bread your book
reengineering humanity posits that
technology is turning us into machines
is it well the the idea behind the book
is to say is to get us to ask ourselves
how often in a life you you feel like or
you behave as if automatically or
comparable to me to a machine right so
the idea of thinking about you know am i
performing a script it may be behaving
habitually or automatically and if so
who wrote that script so the idea is to
think more and more about how the
technical systems the world were
building were really engineering for
ourselves affects who we are as human
beings and how we think how we relate to
each other how we interact with each
other in different settings Tim let me
ask you about the good and bad AI seems
to be a label that's put on everything
these days what does what does the term
AI really mean in the context that we
have here training computers to perform
tasks how do you train a computer that's
right so when you talk about AI it's
important to keep two things separate
one of them is the the marketing of AI
which is what you're referring to and
then there's this sort of computer
science of AI and really that that is a
subfield of artificial intelligence
that's known as machine learning and the
the basics of machine learning that you
need to know is it's sort of the study
of algorithms that get better the more
data that they see so the notion is if
you want to teach a machine to
understand how to recognize a cat in an
image you show it lots of images of cats
and there's a certain set of
methodologies that are used to allow it
to kind of accomplish that task and
really that's the sort of subfield
that's been driving really a lot of the
progress that you've seen in the last
few years
these machines are learning they're
learning machines how does that really
work so a lot of it is based on the
recognition of what's known as features
so for example if you imagine trying to
recognize a cat the example that I just
gave you earlier back in the day the
idea is that you get a bunch of programs
together to think about how they
recognize a cat themselves and then
they'd program explicit rules into
machine so they'd say well a cat's fuzzy
and the cat is usually these kinds of
colors and you actually put those rules
in one of the unique things about
machine learning though is that it's
able to identify these features sort of
by itself after lots and lots of
examples machines can do sort of what
they call inference they're able to say
well in all the cases that I've seen
these are the types of things that are
associated with cats and it turns out
that once you do it that way you get
these systems that are much much better
than we had before in doing these types
of tasks better smarter I'm sure a
defendant depending on how you define
smart that's part of our problem here
today so Meredith you've said that we've
rushed these technologies into some of
the most sensitive areas of our lives
I'm I'm gonna ask your permission to go
off-script
immediately and sort of you answer the
question you asked to Tim because I
think we need to sort of set up where we
are right now socially and politically
and then we can get into some of the
examples but when you know when you ask
what AI now why a AI is you know I have
been in the tech industry for almost 12
years now I have thought a lot about
these issues that's not an easy question
to answer even for somebody who is sort
of a mesh in these technologies and
that's partly because well it's an old
field you know over 60 years old it is
kind of newly adopted in the last five
to ten years and everyone can attest to
this you can't pass a newsstand without
seeing you know another shiny white
robot and some promise of kind of
singularity futures right and I think we
have to ask okay why is this right why
did this just crop up like mushrooms
everywhere we go and when you ask that
question you begin to see that oh this
happened right around the time that big
tech corporations were consolidating
that this business model had sort of
taken over and we're finally you have
these sort of organizations that have
incredible compute power they have super
computing infrastructure they're
actually able to process the massive
amounts of data that is needed to as Tim
said sort of train these systems to
recognize patterns they have this data
because they have vast market reach and
they're able you know from
Facebook - Google - you know whatever
other app you've installed they are able
to continually collect huge amounts of
data they have the infrastructure to set
to store it and then they have
incredibly talented engineers that they
can afford to pay to build these
algorithms so we look at this as sort of
a commodification of a you know earlier
fairly theoretical kind of you know I
would say not not a prominent branch of
computer science for many years that
suddenly became marketable and so we
have to ask when we look at AI whose
stories are were hearing and a lot of
times what we're hearing are the stories
that are written by the marketing
departments of the corporations that
have recognized the marketability and
the profitability of these you know
these techniques that have been around
for a while and that raises the
questions of motives for example you
have written and spoken about the fact
that there are algorithms that claim to
be able to discover which people are
more likely to commit a crime absolutely
and you have to ask you know if you look
at you know one of one of these sort of
you know companies that has claimed to
be able to do this and there are sort of
researchers and sort of you know
businesses that are looking at this as a
technology is axon which used to be
called taser which has a huge cache of
police body cam data so they acquired
two AI companies about a year and a half
ago and are busy creating sort of
real-time facial recognition systems
that will accompany that will analyze
the data captured by police body cams
now their premise is hey police
encounter criminals we have this data
set that will then model criminality
will train the AI to see what a criminal
looks like if you're thinking like
eugenics physiognomy phrenology you're
right and then we will be able to
identify pre-crime innocent until proven
guilty sounds like it's under some kind
of threat yeah yeah yeah it's part of
the concern around the sort of marketing
of it right because I think there is
such a big feeding frenzy over the
promise of the technology and that's
often quite at odds with what the
technology can actually do and so I
think part of the concern is that you
actually see this technology being
deployed in all sorts of situations
where
it's it's not ready for primetime it may
not ever be ready for primetime I think
we have to ask the categorical question
of even if it worked as well as we
believed it did would it still be
something we'd want to do and its effect
on the labor force unemployment you know
again stepping back just a second one of
the real issues with sort of speaking
categorically about these things is that
they are being deployed without our
knowledge so we don't know how often we
encounter a system that classifies us
and as the classified we don't often
know that the you know results the the
opportunities were given or denied the
resources were given or denied were
actually informed by an algorithmic
back-end system there is no transparency
about these systems we don't have
standardized ways to measure them and
they're often sold by vendors to
businesses without informing the public
this is a huge issue I can talk about
there you know what we do know about
their impacts but I think we needs a
sort of level set there that there is a
huge need for transparency and
accountability V do you think that
people since we've heard about the
Facebook scandal and we've heard about
some of these things do you think people
do understand this threat better now I
think far better than they did let's say
three months ago six months ago a year
ago you're gonna have to go like I'm the
the good part of you know a lot of the
current crises is that at least people
are more aware of the way in which you
know technology is impacting their day
to day what information they consume how
they're being manipulated in some cases
and also the recommendation systems that
affect like what they see and what they
believe and I think that that just the
fact that algorithm has become a word
that many people know is a new
phenomenon I think over the last year I
think that that is very valuable because
in the same way that government is the
word people need to know algorithm is
the word people need to know a small
handful of people we're designing a lot
of these come from well they're white
men in the Bay Area as the woman of the
panel
yes they are and their white men in the
Bay Area in the western context and they
are of a similar upper middle class to
very rich social strata
they are often educated with exactly the
same background because to do this we're
not just talking about you know going to
coding camp we're talking about like a
series of very specific advanced degrees
and this is you know for all the best
intentions and some of these people
might dear friends that's a world view
and that's a world view that is embedded
in say the features you choose to
emphasize in your cat detection right
that's a world view that's embedded in
how you say understand gender
classification how you understand some
of these softer relational categories
that's a world view that becomes baked
into this technology that then you know
scales globally you know seriously
globally in ways that are sort of
remapping you know the world according
to that vision and that's you know we
should be worried about that
and indeed the data scientist Cathy
O'Neill has termed a coin for algorithms
that are secret and harmful weapons of
mass destruction yeah that's a good pun
so the key thing that one thing that
would help discourse about these issues
is to always remember that AI is always
will be always should be nothing more
than a tool designed own managed
deployed by human beings and so whenever
you're talking about AI and its impact
or its influence or claims it's never
clinks by AI it's claims about AI made
by purveyors of AI and so it's looking
behind you know peeking behind the hood
looking who owns it who designs that who
manages it and it tends to be
concentrated in in certain ways go ahead
I would just quickly add to that because
I completely agree we also look need to
look at whose power it serves because
when we're talking about the workplace
examples you gave which I complete you
know I've right on right when is the
last time you went to a CVS and the
automated checkout worked right it's not
replacing us anytime soon but what it is
do
what it is doing is it is increasingly
monitoring surveilling and determining
which workers are you know valuable good
and promotable and which aren't and of
course this is trained on data gathered
from the current workforce which shows
you know deep skews and inequity and I
can get into some examples there but you
know this is this is a question of power
alongside a question of exactly how the
technology is constructed okay and just
add one thing about beyond that it's not
just what power it serves but it's also
what power it entrenches as in as a
result of this technology like being
deployed in this way who now has more
power than they had before and what can
they now do with that are there some
areas do any of you feel where this new
technology should never be used some
institutions where algorithms should
never be used I think you know the
question is not do I want to put my foot
down and say never here ever I think the
question is what proof do we have that
they work and how do we validate that
and in most cases we have very little
proof at all we haven't even started
developing the mechanisms to say this is
actually safe this actually you know
works across populations this actually
does what the marketing department says
it does so I think the more sensitive
the area we deploy it into say education
healthcare etc the more we have to wait
until we have those techniques in place
before we try yeah that being said
though I think it is interesting chasing
after problems where you know even if we
did all that verification turns out that
it is better like that for other values
and other reasons we might still say no
I think those classes are very tricky
set of classes where I think like an
injustice context specifically where we
could actually imagine well maybe we
actually do introduce these systems that
are measurably better but maybe there's
something about justice or you know
providing the death sentence actually
requires like a human to be living
question what's better right sure right
better in terms of accuracy with respect
to a scientifically defined or
computation problem that we can all
agree on or better in terms of some set
of values in terms that that may very
well be a fairness equity due process or
other values that aren't necessarily
easily captured in a
in a sort of an empirical question about
accuracy and those are constantly trade
offs across a whole host of areas so one
way to think about it is for every given
case to be made in favor of using AI as
a tool in a particular context of the
sort you were at your doctor's office
for example right so you should compare
alternative tools it's comparing various
tools in context provides a means for
thinking about accuracy effects power
relationships who's behind the tools you
know where is the information flow that
you know behind the scenes or where is
information coming and going from those
are all hosts of complex contextual
variables that aren't easily even you
know captured in most of the
conversations about also add that we we
need to also think about sort of what
are the checks and balances that we're
putting into place as we deploy these
systems maybe it doesn't make sense in
this context even even in this criminal
justice context as we consider the
trade-offs and and our values around it
which is you know absolutely crucial
but then what are the checks to make
sure that this is being used in the way
that we want it to be used because if
we're just dealing with you know black
boxes systems that that doesn't
necessarily fly in some context right
and so now let's look at some more
variables we have to add into this this
recent phenomenon of fake news which
first popped up before the 2016 election
we began seeing dubious news stories
online they were engineered for maximum
disruption what happens when anyone can
make it appear as if anything has
happened regardless of whether it did or
not look at this short film we have on
that difficult question all this
information is coming from all these
different sources and it's getting
harder and harder and harder to
understand and to figure out for
ourselves what is actually true and what
is not and I want you all to know that
we are fighting the fake news it's fake
phony fake
[Applause]
fake news came out of the 2016 election
that that's when it became a thing one
of the scariest advancements in AI
recently has been the machinery that can
be used to create fake video and fake
audio especially our friends who were
lesbian gay bisexual or transgender I
visited with the families of many of the
victims on Thursday I think the
technology to get to the point where
even the media finds the Kecksburg will
not be able to tell what is actually
fake and what is not you don't be
far-fetched to think of it as being used
as maybe a cause for war sometimes a
country releasing a video that shows and
the country is loading nuclear missiles
you know I'm very polite they might use
that as a cause to preemptively strike
that country right you've come at this
issue of fake news from a somewhat
different perspective I think you say
people often ask how can people be so
stupid to believe and engage this way
and you tell them the entire interface
is made to make you believe this way how
is it so right so I got very frustrated
when the fake news story the story about
fate news is sort of breaking and one's
paying attention to it how often I heard
the the the meme I guess that you know
people are stupid and lazy for believing
in fake news and so I would I would
suggest that a lot of the people's
susceptibility or propensity to believe
what they're seeing on various platforms
is is a function of the design of the
platforms so if you're on a social media
network to be named you guys can figure
out which one you want if it's designed
for optimized in its design for rapid
clicking quick scrolling or certain
forms of engagement that the based on
profit where that where the money is to
be made or where data is to be gathered
right that
sort of
this encourages or disincentivizes
people to stop and think or deliberate
or research or ask deeper questions
about the content that they're receiving
and so one one species of fake news
problem is a function of me you know of
making profit right sort of maxing
content to get clicked right they could
care less
those purveyors of that kind of content
could care less about convincing you or
changing your beliefs it's just click to
make money and the platform enables that
the other species is a species of
content that's all about propaganda or
changing beliefs or influencing how
someone approaches a problem and
oftentimes that's not at all about
making money it's about changing beliefs
and to deal with that you need some form
of judgement about the quality the
veracity the sort of provenance of the
information itself or the nature of the
content and our current social media
platforms struggle on both fronts both
in terms of being designed for sort of
certain kinds of engagement that enable
a for-profit model and on the other hand
for not wanting to engage in the
development of editorial judgment or the
exercise of editorial judgment by human
beings
because that that risks putting that an
in sort of a content moderation position
now that started to change since the the
fake news sort of story has blue you've
talked about what this has created a
disease techno social environment and
that were suffering from an engineered
complacency does that frighten any of
you does it threaten you engineered
complacency maybe I should explain what
I mean and then you guys can tell me if
it's right and you it's meant to
frighten me nah no but I mean what I
mean by engineered complacency is that
much of the environment is designed in a
way that repeat interactions in the
environment leads you to feel as if you
have it's futile to resist its heart
there are no other options so if you
think about the easier example than the
fake news context is maybe online
contracting
right so what do you do when you see an
I agree putt and pop up on a website you
know not always but most people most of
the time click I agree right as you're
supposed to
by virtue of both the design of the site
and the interface as well as the nature
of the take-it-or-leave-it
interaction that you're having in each
of the transaction plus the fact that
you your repeat interactions with that
interface over time so even if you
thought you know what maybe I'll stop
and think about the legal relationship
I'm entering into for some of the
websites that I'm visiting or some of
the apps that I'm downloading or some of
the devices on installing and in my home
how do you decide which of the many
different encounters with the interface
would cause you to stop and think indeed
that raises another question are we
actually changing the way the brain
operates to what effect is this Tim well
I would say I'm not a neuroscientist but
I mean I think there are there is habit
formation right I think there's no doubt
about that and I think one of the things
that Brett's pointing out which I think
is really great is that your experience
of certain elements online train you for
how you behave in future experiences
with that right so I could even imagine
a sort of strange world that we're in
right now where we say everybody gets
together and they all agree that this
situation is really bad and we should do
something about it and and we actually
changed like how the design of the
software looks but actually people's
behaviors are actually stuck in a format
that will make those behaviors sticky
over time right so you could actually
imagine like let's just bust up and shut
down Facebook tomorrow whether or not it
actually recreates itself as a result of
the fact that the market now is sort of
entrained in certain ways I think that's
an interesting possibility and really
challenging what if you think about the
fact that these two variables actually
related right that that people are
influenced but then they actually kind
of influence the production in the
system in return you're nodding I was
just agreeing that that I think this is
another example of sort of the
entrenchment of power or here it's not
even power in a particular organization
but its power in a particular almost
like process or way of using your
yourself and your brain and and your
environment I would add you
I I agree and I would say it you know
and yet it is power in a particular
organization I have never known a
product manager or engineer to you know
get promoted for reducing engagement
right there are you know certain types
of incentive structures that are driving
the culture and ecosystems of these
companies and even if you're engaging
with sort of propaganda that is not
there to make money for clicks the
longer you stay on a site the more sort
of adrenal izing content you're exposed
to the more ads they show you right so
there is a monetary incentive in these
sort of AD you know bad business
platforms to keep people on the site
which I think you know the politics of
that are becoming clear the risks of
that are becoming clear but the business
model sort of remains please pretty
sclerotic yeah yeah I must add like one
wrinkle to this discussion though to say
I think a lot about the this sort of
catch-22 that platforms find themselves
in right because they can say okay we're
not going to take action in which case
the public is like you're negligent you
didn't take action and they're like okay
okay so we're gonna take action and then
they're like you're imposing your
ethical will on me right and I think
this actually is part of the tricky
thing that needs to be dealt with
because I think when people ask the
question Facebook do you have a
responsibility here the question is like
should they be the ones who are
delegated that responsibility that ends
up being I think a very interesting and
tricky question and I worry about
situations where we say they could just
do better because in some ways that sort
of reinforces their position and making
a lot of these decisions as well right
and so we may need to actually even
rethink the the sort of governance that
has designed in a much bigger way yeah I
would I would caution against us then
mentality in general I mean so I think
often times but it's it varies big
context and it varies by the technology
we're talking about and the rest of you
must have strong feelings about this I
mean yeah I wonder actually a little bit
about and I'm concerned about the sort
of what I called the sort of the Overton
Window of crisis here the over
yeah the Overton Window of crisis so
Overton Window it's a concept for
political science that talks about like
what's politically acceptable
right and the notion is that certain
events occasionally will happen that
will widen that window right where
someone breaks various storms and
politics and suddenly a whole lot of
activity is allowed that it wasn't
allowed before becomes plausible in a
way that wasn't and I think there was a
view actually early on around these
privacy debates which is okay people
don't care about privacy right now but
we just need to wait until the first big
crisis right in the first big data
bridge and then everybody will care
about privacy right and then that moment
came and went and they came and went and
came away and came away and you get this
feeling now that actually like that like
state of affairs has been normalized in
a way that actually makes it quite
difficult to mobilize change politically
within the ministry you know I was
talking to a person who does product
management recently and I was like oh
well you know this product you're
building you could kind of improve it
next y-z ways and he said well you know
we're gonna get we're gonna get blamed
by the Public Enemies no matter what we
do so we're just gonna do it right and I
think that's a really interesting
phenomenon where basically the response
has been so kind of built into the
process that that creates a level of
apathy aunt of itself and the
effectiveness of dissent has been sort
of muted so much that you know that's
just part of it you look at the media
for a while then you know there may be
some stories about it but it's not
actually there's no sort of effective
organizing I mean I I guess another
thing about this is you know I find the
current framework of privacy kind of
broken to talk about a lot of what we're
speaking about right I don't you know I
don't know that I've ever personally
felt or detected harm from a privacy
breach although you know I've been in
all sorts of databases that have leaked
because of you know egregious security
practices but I do know that we have
collective harm's right and I think you
know we we need to begin thinking about
these things collectively and we need to
begin you know it's not it's not I keep
my personal data safe it's that we have
you know major interest you know the
federal government and the sort of Smart
Watch or whatever it is you know large
tech companies who are interested in
understanding this data and then you
know creating profiles of us based on
the data right so I may not have
contributed my data but I am suddenly
profiled because there is a model about
you know
childhood activity that you know who
knows where that's gonna go is that
going to be used to sort of you know
wait college admissions will that be
sent to insurance companies to see you
know whose family gets insurance right
but we don't you know we have not asked
for sort of transparency or oversight
into these kinds of processes and
assumptions and so when we talk about
privacy it's often sort of a very thin
debate because I don't have time to do
my laundry let alone like read through a
TOS and then take responsibility for
where all of my data is right I think
things to really keep in mind here is
that there are really hard trade-offs to
be made when you're thinking about
privacy so like one example is if that's
you're talking about you know
misinformation in the 2016 election or
even stuff that's being spread in let's
say in Myanmar where you might have
people creating fake accounts and those
fake accounts are spreading this
propaganda right I mean that propaganda
is causing violence or it's you know
misinforming voters well how does a
facebook go in actually detect those
fake accounts well they're looking at
the IPS of all these users they're
they're looking at every single signal
they can possibly get on that user and
comparing it to what they know are sort
of real users and to tell the difference
and so if if they don't have that data
they can't make that comparison then
that makes their job a lot harder in
protecting our democracy if they're
active trying to do that which they now
since we are and so I think that that we
really there are some very very
difficult balances that we need to
strike in order to ensure that we
protect our democracy you protect our
privacy we protect our ability to speak
freely all of these things are sort of
in the balance and there's a lot of
values better-better intention and so
you've set up the big question then
we're now gonna I guess moved the
inevitable hopeful side of this what are
the if we can find one what are the
fixes what are we gonna do Tim how can
we make this AI more ethical sure so one
of the things I think about particularly
related to this discussion is the
delegation question that I mentioned a
little while back right which is that
particular after 2016 were kind of in
this tough spot where we're basically
like companies just solve the problem
well we feel really uncomfortable about
Facebook telling us what's true or not
all right well then let's pass a law and
then you're like oh well like we don't
actually want governments to tell us
what's true or not and so there's
actually this moment of like we have to
delegate to these two wolves
both of them like we feel fracture
pretty uncomfortable working with them
on issues of truth for instance and
there seems to like their particular
after 2016 there's there's a general
sort of implosion I think in our faith
around the ability for like communities
to self organize and deal with some of
these problems themselves and I think
that there is good intellectual work to
be done in terms of trying to figure out
how platforms can make those things more
robust yes and aviv i see you nodding a
great deal and we were hearing also
every week from the platforms that are
stepping up twitter says it's going to
limit tweets from people behaving badly
and facebook has just detailed policing
for sex terror and hate content do you
think they're going far enough i think
there's a number of steps that are in
the right direction there's gonna be
some sex that backtrack as we learn more
and as we discover that oh wait this
isn't exactly what we wanted and i mean
that's part of this process and i'm
happy that we're actually on this
process as opposed to just ignoring it
which was sort of you know the status
quo two years ago when you know they
said you know fake news was a 2016
problem that's in the US right a lot of
the rest of the world has been you know
dealing with its information that's very
deeply affecting their political systems
for you know 5-10 years even so i mean i
think that there are some some things
that really do need to happen and
they're starting to happen within these
organizations in particular you've got
you know empower like you're we need to
have like empowered teams that can look
at the impacts of the technologies on
these things that we care about on let's
say our democracy on the like inter
community trust so that you're not just
increasing polarization if you don't
have someone who's paid to ensure that
your platform isn't like deeply
polarizing things well then your growth
team that's trying to get more users and
running get more action is might
unintentionally just do that there has
to be that back and forth and they have
to be empowered enough to sort of push
back just this fascinating possible
solutions to some of it empowered by
whom i mean well with both within the
organization and ideally with some sort
of external accountability where you you
know across these organizations whether
like
there's a number of different structures
but the idea is that you not only have
some sort of internal structure that's
keeping an eye on you know this with
people who their job responsibilities is
to maintain some of these things that we
care about but you also have outside of
the company some way in which you're
able to see oh is that company doing a
good job at this and whether that's you
know through regulatory process maybe
maybe not but but I think that there has
to be some structure that creates those
power dynamics so an independent
idealistic new profession that we need
to live in this new world I mean I don't
know that it's new I mean social
scientists have been doing this sort of
work for you know a million years but
maybe not a million oh don't quote me on
that but but I think the combination is
sort of that like people looking at how
how the technologies impacting society
and really sort of cross functionally
and having teams that are doing that and
and are that is their focus to
understand the way these platforms are
impacting things and I think even beyond
that when you're talking about something
like these deep fakes
that's about not just research that's
have not just stuff that's happening in
these these companies in these platforms
but it's up happening in research labs
where you have researchers who are just
like Oh wouldn't this be cool oh I can
get a good paper out of this and that's
great you know I love good papers I love
cool things but it doesn't mean that you
shouldn't be looking at sort of what are
the potential negative impacts and one
thing that I'm I've been really excited
to see is people within an academic
community starting to really think about
this deeply and there's actually as of
now as of like a few days ago the if you
go to like negative impact org there's
this you know this group the ACM
computing fellow ACM computing of the
future something along those lines where
they're looking at the ways in which of
the ways in which we can improve the
peer review process to really
incorporate not just the positive
impacts of a technology but also keeping
in mind a negative impacts we have just
a couple of minutes left
so your thoughts about where you we're
headed if we don't get we don't get I
mean we're clearly had a de climate
crisis we're clearly headed to a lot of
really serious issues that relate to
this and don't relate to this but I want
to I want to back up a little and you
know make space for the question of what
world do we actually want do we want
Facebook to be you know negotiating with
the US government to determine sort of
truthiness or do we want Facebook right
is it you know do we want like
capitalism right what is what do we want
this to be and then think about what
types of technologies could you build or
avoid building to create that because I
think we get we fall into the trap of
accepting the status quo and then time
to tweak it around the edges and it's
very clear that that's not at this point
working and that a number of the major
social problems we're facing are a mesh
deeply with the major technological
issues and they're being exacerbated in
ways that are you know very complex to
tease apart from a systems perspective
so you know I would want to start with
the imaginative potential of how do we
create a better world and then see do we
want these sort of bulwarks of power in
this world in that where are we headed
if we don't fix it I think we're heading
to it the you know science fiction
dystopia where we are more and more of
our lives are determined are predicted
and determined by technological systems
controlled by a few how we avoid that
the 24 the Constitution was fundamental
issue for us to confront in the 21st
century is how to sustain our freedom to
be off so that we're not always on how
to build techno social environments
through technology and social
institutions that preserve
underdetermined environments within
which we can develop play experiment
interact with each other in ways that
allow us to develop our own lives rather
than that have them determined for us
something for the lawyers the
politicians and
but they get involved with including you
nerds who have given us all this stuff
let's give a round of applause thank you
for sharing
[Applause]
[Music]